alors le coup de coeur du ciné set une
fois n'est pas coutume cette semaine
c'est un film de répertoire
le très connu little big man pardon fils
de 2h19 de 1971 d'arthur penn qui est
ressortie en salles en version restaurée
alors little big man faut absolument
voir sur filles c'est un chef-d'oeuvre
comme je viens de le dire
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui à 123
ans donc qui est au seuil de sa vie et
qui raconte son histoire
donc c'est un visage pâle qui a été
recueillie par des cheyennes geste en
dire beaucoup plus
et qui va raconter un petit peu tous les
événements qui ont jalonné sa vie donc
l'interprétation est extraordinaire
c'est dustin hoffman qui tient le rôle
principal
il est formidable donc évidemment les
maquillages etc etc etc surtout une
version du fus du genre western qui est
unique en son genre parce que le récit
s'apparente absolument pas au western
classique on a l'habitude de voir dans
les salles de cinéma dont vous n'hésitez
pas c'est vendredi soir aussi le 7 à
20h45 venez découvrir ou redécouvrir
little big man
[Musique]